so when you wrote the main character for
day out of days what what port out of
you like did you see this person in your
mind this is did you see this woman and
what was it that just you said you wrote
it so quickly I did I know a lot of
actresses I tried to be an actress and I
was younger was terrible at it but at
least I had the experience and the
humiliation of it so I just thought what
it was was just such a tough place you
know to be and it fits so well with that
idea about aging you know God forbid
were old at 40 but you know if 40 is the
new 30 it's like something I wrote it's
like but it's not the new 30 in
Hollywood and it's not the new 30 in
life I mean we feel this vitality but
you know it's something we still have to
fight against fighting the fighting the
clock always fighting the clock so what
what about that story land and that this
character really poured out of you mean
also too and not just ageism but also
you have to be like this perfect little
hostess I think a lot of times and and
in terms of you know meeting people and
of course you want to be cordial but I
think there's the pressure to to be that
as well oh it's all I mean it's awful I
hate being put on the spot in those
situations personally so I think it's
about someone who has to kind of break
their own egg you know and it it's so
easy to put the layers on it's so easy
for me for a lot of people in the world
just to put the layers on and not ask
the important questions and not take the
scary chances and ultimately not be
happy and fulfilled in life very easy
much harder to take all the chances
break the egg and find some sort of you
know happiness
you